good morning the rules
committee is called to order
please be advised that an
audio video recordings being
made of today's proceedings
and it is also being televised
secretary please call the roll
Cunningham Carillo flora
Grayson Kamlager-Dove here
Maienschein Mathis quirk Silva
Ramos Rivas yeah Wicks
Levine we have a quorum
we have a quorum and we
also the consent agenda
so we have a motion a second
was sherry spitefully object
to the referral ACA fourteen
this measure directly affect
the operation of our UC system
based on the referral of
they should be the higher
Education Committee I therefore
require that we vote separately
thank you for that and so we
will vote separately on that
particular item and -- we do
have a motion and a second so
secretary please call the roll
on the remainder of that can
for the remainder of the consent
agenda -- Carillo flora
for aye Grayson aye
Grayson aye Kamlager-Dove
Kamlager-Dove I Maienschein
Maienschein aye Mathis Mathis
first of aye Ramos Ramos I Rivas
Rivas aye works hi Wicks I
Levine Levine I've motion passes
the motion was passed is there a
motion on the single referral of
a CA fourteen Gonzalez to labor
and employment the bill sorry
so we have a motion and a second
secretary please call the
roll Cunningham Carillo
for Mel flora no Grayson
by Grayson aye Kamlager-Dove
hi cam honored of aye
Maienschein Maienschein aye
Mathis Mathis no Burke Silva
hi five Ramos strive
for almost aye results
I lex hi Wicks I
living Levine the high
referral of the suit --
fourteen I I have Carillo
aye motion passes the motion
is passed the assembly
rules committee is adjourned
one Adeline St yeah